héros passe maintenant à notre terriens
du samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aristide barraud bonsoir
alors elle si vous avez été
l'un des grands espoirs du rugby
français vainqueur notamment du tournoi
des six nations des moins de 20 ans en
2009 quand vous jouiez à l'époque au
stade français mais le 13 novembre 2015
votre vie bascule ce soir là vous êtes à
la terrasse du restaurant le petit
cambodge quand l'horreur se déchaînent
vous jeter sur votre soeur alice pour la
protéger et vous prenez trois balles de
kalachnikov vous voyez mourir et là
notre mental exceptionnel et votre
entourage vous permettre de revenir à la
vie alors vous racontez votre histoire
dans un livre intitulé mais ne sombre
pas qui est publié aux éditions du seuil
il ce soir dans salut les terriens alors
aristide vous êtes né le 10 e place
à saint cloud issu d'une famille de
prolétaires qui travaille pour la régie
renault vous dites mon sang est celui
des laborieux qui luttent et ne lâche
rien je ne peux pas les renier ce sens
me donne la force c'est vrai que tout le
monde était au tour de l'île seguin quoi
du côté de ma mère mes grands parents
étaient ouvriers chez renault mon
grand-père dans les fonderies et ma
grand mère dans les ateliers intégrés
dans les cantines voilà du côté de mon
père c'était
que signer une origine paysanne du
milieu de la france 2 du puy-de-dôme et
j'ai beaucoup pensé c'est vrai pendant
cette période là où penser à mes anciens
ça m'a souvent donné beaucoup de force a
dit également l'histoire du grand père
adolphe en fait il s'est rebaptisé
alfred quand adolf hitler est arrivé au
pouvoir il était caporal de la coloniale
à la tête d'une escouade de tirailleurs
sénégalais il avait pris un éclat d'obus
dans la tête et les médecins lui avaient
annoncé qu'ils finiraient séjour dans un
lit allongé sans pouvoir bouger mais il
se bat et toutes les nuits il s'extrait
de son lit ils rampent sur le sol pour
rejoindre la salle où sont entreposées
des armes pour se tuer en fait ouais
c'est exactement ça il avancé les
médecins le retrouver toujours un petit
peu plus loin dans le couloir et c'est à
ce moment là qu'ils se sont dit que
peut-être il allait pouvoir s'en sortir
et remarcher rebouché
c'était une figure importante pour moi
depuis tout petit il avait reçu aussi la
légion d'honneur il avait pris l'eau bue
en essayant de sauver des certains de
ses hommes donc c'était une figure
importante pour moi même si on n'en
parlait pas trop où j'avais toujours eu
des conversations avec ma grand mère sa
fille sur sur ceux sur cet ancêtre
et surtout c'est cette phrase de ma
grand mère qui me semblent importantes
c'est une des premières fois ce qu'elle
m'a dit comme a vu arriver en fauteuil
roulant elle a passé son enfance à
autour des gueules cassées des anciens
combattants des invalides de guerre et
elle m'a dit en fait ce qui ce qui me
remue le plus dans tout ça c'est que
cent ans après
dow jones ont tué des jeunes pour rien
ouais alors alfred finira par retrouver
la parole et une certaine mobilité vous
est costaud la famille a quand même vous
avez ouais ouais alors jusqu'en 1998
jusqu'à l'âge de 9 ans ou iv à châtenay
malabry et du balcon de l'appartement
vous voyez les sportifs de haut niveau
entrer et sortir du creps le creps un
centre d'entraînement etc
et là vous dites quand même je voudrais
devenir comme eux quoi c'est un modèle
là aussi qui s'offrent à vous vous devez
avoir un beau sac de sport et puis vous
entraîner tous les jours c'était votre
votre ambition oui je voulais je voulais
être sportif de haut niveau déjà tout
petit je sais même pas encore dans quel
sport ouais
ensuite la famille emménage dans un
pavillon que tout le monde a aidé à
construire c'est assez beau parce que
tout le monde s'y met les voisins la
famille construisant un très beau
pavillon à massy-palaiseau là vous avez
des amis à ce moment là de tous les
continents de toutes les religions à
commencer par mamadou et vous parlez de
ce même à dos en disant sa maman était
belle comme un masque africain moi
j'essaie souvenir 1 il y avait un
iranien chez qui vous alliez faire
devoir donc un iranien dont la famille
avait fui le régime de l'eat l'arménie
n'ont effectivement vous êtes en contact
avec toutes sortes de populations et
vous dites la banlieue m'a appris la
tolérance la banlieue m'a appris la
tolérance la banlieue m'a appris
la richesse de l'humain de la différence
est vrai que c'est pas les endroits les
plus faciles à vivre mais
j'ai toujours réussi à voir ce qu'ils
avaient de beaux dans chaque situation
et c'est quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
servi willis était à revivre je ne
voudrais d'aucune autre enfant sans fin
n'étiez pas très riche mais c'était
enrichissant j'ai vu c'est exactement ça
j'ai l'impression d'avoir vécu une
enfance de richesse l'amitié la wii la
tolérance la différence de la diversité
la différence en avait 10 ans quand vous
découvrez le rugby est aussitôt vous
décidez que vous deviendrez
professionnel et vous avez tout
sacrifier pour atteindre cet objectif
aristide alors de travailler dur dans la
journée au collège thomas cas ces
travailleurs tout ça pour vous voir vous
entraîner le soir
pas le temps d embrouille avec les potes
pas l'temps des meufs vraiment bosseur
moi j'ai
j'avais envie de me dégager du temps
pour m'entraîner j'étais pas un bon
joueur c'était un super joueur alors au
delà du petit terrain de sable défoncer
sur lequel vous jouez le rugby la ville
de massy palaiseau devient votre salle
de sport vous courez sur la passerelle
de la gare donc fait 200 m elle aussi
d'éviter les les gens les piétons qui
sont là un peu comme au rugby
zeese et la rue et le mobilier urbain
pour vous entraîner et bien les années
plus tard vous ferez une vidéo qu'on
regarde
au dessus
[Musique]
alors on s'y joignent décidé d'entrer au
lycée lakanal de sceaux et la c1 quoi
jusqu'à huit joueurs par génération qui
sont retenus et en 2004 dont vous avez
15 ans vous gagnez votre pari vous entre
air la can c'est un pari difficile très
fou on aurait surtout au niveau scolaire
en fait ouais moi j'arrivais de zone ou
assez faible au niveau scolaire il a
fallu vraiment rattraper beaucoup de
retard c'est un délice et les plus
réputés d'île de france c'est un vrai
château en fait c'est un château avec un
parc et j'ai vite progresser en fait
j'ai vite malgré ces sa douce en 2008
donc à l'âge de 18 ans vous décrocher le
graal vous signé au stade français là
vous avez été entraînés quand même par
fabien galthié grand joueur de rugby
s'il en est mais en fait le monde des
pros rapidement vous déçoit vous dites
c'est le monde où l'on joue pour gagner
sa vie alors que jusque là faisait
oublier jouer uniquement pour le plaisir
et vous découvrez aristide que vous
n'êtes pas assez égoïste assez
nombriliste pour vous intéresser
vraiment au monde des rugbymen
professionnels je dirais que c'est un
quotidien qui m'a frustré puisque c'est
un quotidien on se concentre beaucoup
sur
préparer le match donc il faut préparer
son corps préparer sa tête bien manger
se reposer et j'avais l'impression
souvent de gâcher ma jeunesse en fait de
gâcher ma jeunesse pour un objectif
extrêmement égoïste en fait et je me
suis pas bien senti à ma place sa mère
partage quand même pas de gagner en 2009
le tournoi des six nations des moins de
20 ans j'ai quand même très très bien et
la fin 2015 donc vous jouez à ce moment
là en italie pour le club de moyano donc
vous rentrer à paris pour voir des amis
pour voir votre heure pour voir votre
famille et vous voulez vous faire un
petit resto avec des potes c'est le
programme du 13 novembre 2015 ce jour-là
vous retrouvé vos potes aïda bastien
laura et votre soeur alice à votre qg de
la rue de charonne qui s'appelle le
pause-café vous avez sélectionné 50
droit pour aller dîner le petit cambodge
était le dernier sur la liste vous
finissez par y aller pourquoi
ce que j'avais envie de manger des nems
et c'est les meilleurs hélas alors que
vous êtes devant le restaurant l'horreur
éclatent à 21h25
devant le feu des kalachnikovs vous vous
jeter au sol et là vous recouvrez le
corps de votre soeur de votre corps pour
la protéger vous prenez trois balles une
dans la cheville une dans la cuisse une
dans le poumon votre soeur alice en
prend une dans le poignet
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au moment où
vous dites je me jette sur elle pour la
pour la sauver elle tant pis je vais y
passer mais je la sors ça a été
instinctif en fait c'est très vu le jeu
je n'explique même pas même dans le
livre je l'aï dit et je n'explique pas
ça parce que c'est quelque chose qui
s'est passé je pense tout simplement
qu'on est on a des réactions animal
quand
on se trouvent dans des situations
extrêmement dangereuses et l'instinct à
parler pour moi ça donc
j'ai eu cet instinct qui nous a permis
de nous sauver tous les deux je remercie
cet instinct j'ai du mal à lire que vous
acceptez votre mort si votre soeur
survie c'est ça l'histoire oui c'est à
peu près ça qui s'est passé dans ma tête
je ne pouvais pas imaginer
[Musique]
que nous mourions tous les deux ouais je
me suis dis hein ça va deux noms l'art
est au sol perdait beaucoup de sang
et dans l'appartement au dessus du petit
cambodge miracle quand même bien serge
simon sert simon est une star du rugby
évidemment qui est devenue médecin qui
regarde pas la fnath qui descend au
courant et là vous vous rappelez de sa
voix comme si sa voix était sorti d'un
mégaphone il vit je suis médecin
pour que nécessaire connu j'ai reconnu
sa tête j'ai ramené sa tête moi j'étais
déjà en mauvaise posture c'est ma soeur
qui l'a appelée monde ouvert les yeux il
y avait sa tête devant moi il dit
je m'appelle serge plée reconnu tout de
suite
là votre état se détériore beaucoup vous
n'arrivez plus à garder les yeux ouverts
vous partez très loin vous ne souhaitez
plus rien et vous lui dites un serment
écoute serge c'est maintenant ou plus
jamais parce que vraiment voilà il
fallait qu'il s'occupe de vous là il se
redresse s'il attrape en brancard bref
nous sauve la vie quoi elle est
exceptionnelle mouais mais est
exceptionnel il a su
[Musique]
diriger les premiers gestes les premiers
soins il a su diriger mes amis mettent
les mains au bon endroit pour
qui il a su gérer les premiers moments
et
je serai été compliqué sur lui alors
votre copine aïda vous accompagne aux
urgences elle sent que vous partez la
boutique laquelle dit moi je sais que tu
as le mental c'est maintenant qu'il faut
le montrer
g
j'ai des souvenirs très très floue de
ces moments là ouais mais j'ai pris une
bonne tarte web et puis après c'est
interminable reconstruction les
opérations qui s'enchaînent cinq côtes
pulvérisé le sternum ouvert en deux
cercle et parvis fil de fer d'études de
deux centimètres de diamètre entrant au
niveau des abdos des côtes
60 à graver dans le dos et dans la
poitrine des mois en fauteuil et avec
des béquilles j'ai passé cinq mois sans
forcer le pied à terre ça a été ça a été
un
le long parcours je dirais même une une
formation accélérée pour beaucoup de
choses ça a été une lutte
interne une lutte pour mon entourage
aussi on a fait ça ensemble on a n'a su
prendre
bataille après bataille à chaque fois à
retourner à l'hôpital recommencer
et j'avais
jamais un objectif bien précis en tête
donc ça m'a permis de garder le cap sans
compter les maux de tête hallucinations
les hallucinations c'était dû au
traitement
vosges octobre six collèges et le choc
psychologique le traitement très très
lourd et aussi les cauchemars l'ailé les
effets 10 ans du syndrome du syndrome
post traumatique précisément j'ai
l'impression d'avoir touché des zones
de l'inconscience qui sont rarement
atteintes en fait tu décris s'il ya des
moments où j'essaie de décrire ça dans
le livre pas du tout pour m'apitoyer et
face de toute façon le livre est
totalement étranger à la moindre plainte
ou mais simplement pour pour témoigner
deux
de ces moments qui sont spécifiques à
aux blessures très graves et aussi
essayer de d'expliquer de trouver des
enjeux plus universel quoi que l'on vit
tous à travers cette expérience hors du
commun
vous dites je me gorgen musique à
l'époque il ya un morceau vous écouter
très souvent
[Musique]
nous
je
[Musique]
alors donc à l'époque voulait rejouer au
rugby voulais rejouer vite au rugby puis
un an vous
voilà vous décidé de renoncer au rugby
c'est le plus dur ça non j'ai accepté
l'inévitable c'est et ça je pense que
j'ai je voulais aller au bout du chemin
absolument je veux je ne voulais pas
laisser quelqu'un décider de ma vie et
de décider de mon parcours et
j'ai voulu retourner sur le terrain en
me disant même si c'est que cinq minutes
au moins j'ai bouclé la boucle et c'est
moi qui décide de l'arrêt de ma carrière
mais après un an et demi de lutte de
d'opération c'est sans douleur et puis
j'ai commencé à me rendre compte que je
me battais contre moi-même en fait je me
battais contre mon propre corps je
luttais avec le mental mais
j'ai mon corps m'a envoyé des signaux
importants
et je gens ça suffit doit il ya eu des
moments très très difficiles et j'ai eu
peur j'ai eu peur j'ai eu plein de wayne
je pensais que vraiment là
c'est ce chemin difficile allait
m'amener jusqu'au terrain est en fait il
m'a amené jusqu'à l'acceptation
c'est déjà quelque chose c'était déjà
quelque chose je suis maintenant heureux
2-2 de ne pas avoir lâché simplement
c'est c'était important pour moi alors
avant de se quitter j'aimerais qu'on
regarde un extrait d'un documentaire qui
s'appelle alice et aristide un
documentaire de laëtitia krupa qui a été
diffusé sur la chaîne l'équipe et qui
est produit par victor robert qu'on
salue en
[Musique]
et
nous observons
[Musique]
parce que c'était un futur emprunt dont
moi j'étais entré avant
[Musique]
ce qui est incroyable c'est que à
quelques mois après
la vie reprend ses inarrêtable tu peux
jean pierre d or
et pierres des travailleurs a toujours
quelques mois après
une herbe qui va pousser une fleur qui
s'en fout quoi
parce que c'est
dareta de la victime ait
alors on voit donc avec un ciel chinois
c'est des amis c'est un ancien de ses
amis d'enfance de son enfance à nice qui
habitent là qui travaillait à la télé
désormais et il était chez eux comme
tous les vendredis soir puisqu'il
animait une émission de radio
il était là voilà simplement ça bouge
essaye même pas de nous l'expliquer j'y
pense bien mais incroyable c'est
beaucoup trop c'est beaucoup voilà dans
neuf jours
on sera le 13 novembre merci de votre
témoignage il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou